okay andy from that ufo podcast as well
and the links to all of this are in the
description ufology has changed so much
in the past three or four years let
alone three or four decades how have
your views or opinions in that time
changed how do you see your place in the
subject now
oh
ufology
uh as a a word means nothing to me
means literally nothing to me
if we're talking about what are
hard physical data
on planet earth
that has been linked
to aerial phenomena that glows put down
beams where there have been eyewitnesses
who have seen animals rise in a beam
lowered in a beam
humans who have said that they have been
on the ground and have seen a beam come
down and then they're taken up in a beam
that's called eyewitness testimony
from other humans about something that
they have seen
and then the physical evidence in this
case are the animals
thousands and thousands and thousands of
domestic and wild animals
around this planet going back to at
least the 1950s and the early 1960s as a
beginning
have been affected the same way
there were so many reports of serrated
edges
in the united states for example and
canada
in the 1970s that sheriffs and deputies
kept referring to them as cookie cutter
cuts
that is
evidentiary
you've got
eyewitnesses you have a phenomena that
does not change it keeps repeating
this is the animal mutilation phenomena
that sheriffs and deputies came to the
conclusion as sheriff tex graves told me
in colorado in 1979
the perpetrators linda are creatures
from outer space
it was a shocking statement
but i emphasize again
everything in my working world for the
decade before i started on mutilations
graduating from stanford in 1968
being hired
at these different stations
and i did not start on a strange harvest
till 79 so a decade later it's the same
approach
i go to veterinarians
i pay for necropsies
i went to labs
i looked at reports
that's
what i have done that has absolutely
nothing to do with quote unquote the
word ufology